tras los agobiantes pedidos de ayuda
este convoy de la ONU logró entrar al
noroeste de Siria una zona controlada
por Rebeldes y fuertemente golpeada por
los terremotos del 6 de febrero la
comunidad internacional había criticado
repetidamente la falta de asistencia
humanitaria en esta región que ha
soportado casi 12 años de guerra civil y
bombardeos
esta campaña es para todas las personas
aquí en el norte de Siria no habrá
discriminación esta campaña no es la
última hay campañas en el cruce y otras
campañas están en las áreas del este y
el norte listas para cruzar el convoy de
11 camiones cargados con asistencia
humanitaria cruzó por la frontera con
Turquía de bab al jaguar y se espera que
el gobierno sirio cumpla con su
compromiso de abrir más pasos
fronterizos pese al escepticismo de los
locales los terremotos afectaron con más
fuerza a la zona controlada por Rebeldes
y no solo la ayuda humanitaria ha sido
escasa sino que la zona no cuenta con de
rescate suficientes pero algunos han
decidido ayudar por su cuenta como este
grupo de voluntarios que instaló
clínicas móviles en llandaris para
afrontar otro reto que dejó la
catástrofe
el principal desafío es que perdimos
mucho personal médico en el terremoto
una gran cantidad de personal médico en
el área murió mientras que otros
perdieron familiares o parientes y por
lo tanto estaban preocupados y alejados
del servicio médico creando una escasez
a pesar de los intentos de ayuda la
falta de suministros médicos dificultan
las labores por su parte la OMS advirtió
sobre el riesgo de enfermedades
relacionadas con la higiene y el
saneamiento especialmente en Siria donde
la situación Real de la tragedia tardará
en conocerse